Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sama Sambuddhassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sama Sambuddhassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sama Sambuddhassa
Hommage au Bouddha, celui qui est béni et qui s'est éveillé par l'humain entièrement.
J'ai promis de révéler tellement de choses ce soir que je suis sûr de décevoir quelqu'un.
J'ai promis de révéler tellement de choses ce soir que je suis sûr que je vais désappointer quelqu'un.
Juste avant d'entrer dans la pièce, quelqu'un m'a posé une autre question encore par rapport à l'ouverture que l'on appelle l'équanimité.
Dans ce qu'on appelle les sept facteurs d'éveil, qui mènent à l'éveil, l'équanimité c'est ce qui équilibre l'investigation, c'est-à-dire l'approfondissement du Dhamma, des enseignements du Bouddha.
Les sept facteurs sont l'awareness, et puis il y a l'énergie et la concentration.
Et ensuite, il y a l'énergie et la concentration.
Donc, quand il y a trop d'énergie, on est agité.
Quand on n'a pas assez d'énergie, on tombe dans le sommeil.
Les deux suivants sont le calme et l'intérêt.
La raison pour laquelle Jean
j'étais surprise parce qu'effectivement le mot que le Venerable a dit par intérêt en général le facteur ça s'appelle la joie quand c'est traduit par ça en fait ce mot Pali qui se dit Piti a beaucoup de contextes différents traduits différemment
dans les facteurs de l'éveil l'intérêt c'est un état joyeux n'est-ce pas ?
s'intéresser à quelque chose c'est quelque chose d'agréable n'est-ce pas ?
Et les deux autres sont l'équanimité et l'investigation du Dhamma.
Et six de ces facteurs peuvent être développés de toute manière dans votre vie.
l'attention, l'effort, la concentration, l'intérêt, le calme, et l'équanimité.
Et ce qui fait que tous ces facteurs deviennent des facteurs d'éveil, c'est le septième, c'est-à-dire l'investigation des enseignements du Bouddha.
Donc l'équanimité est
L'équanimité, ça veut dire se placer dans une position où il n'y a pas d'a priori, il n'y a pas de croyances qui viennent avant ce qu'on va découvrir.
Il n'y a pas non plus de peur ou d'aversion qui nous empêcherait de recevoir, d'être récepteur.
il n'y a pas non plus d'attachement ni de préjugé donc c'est une attitude où l'esprit est très ouvert le coeur est complètement ouvert donc sur un niveau physique quand on marche dans le jardin c'est juste d'être conscient
sur un plan très simple, sur un plan physique, par exemple quand on marche dans le jardin, cette équanimité consiste simplement à être conscient de ce qui se passe, il y a le vent, il y a le soleil, on est présent, on est réceptif.
Et quand il s'agit d'être équanime à l'intérieur, c'est recevoir tout ce qui arrive, que ce soit agréable ou désagréable, tout ce qui monte en nous, nous l'acceptons.
Dans la vie quotidienne, quand on entre dans une certaine situation, l'idée c'est d'être ouvert à la totalité de la situation.
Nous avons des visions sur certaines personnes.
On a par exemple des images arrêtées sur certaines personnes.
Et ça, il arrive souvent que ça bloque la communication.
Mais si on arrive à réouvrir cette ouverture par rapport à la personne, la communication peut recommencer.
Et cela nécessite d'autres vertus comme le courage, la patience, etc.
L'équanimité est, selon la compréhension du maître formateur Nyanaponika, un monk allemand qui est mort il y a quelques années.
C'était un moine allemand qui est décédé il y a quelques années.
Il a écrit quelques très bons livres.
Par exemple, il y en a un qui est toujours un classique, ça s'appelle Le cœur de la méditation bouddhiste.
Et dans un autre livre qu'on appelle La vision du Dhamma, il écrit à propos de ces qualités, justement.
il dit que la plus grande de toutes les vertus c'est l'équanimité parce que l'équanimité est ce qui permet à toutes les autres vertus d'exister par exemple c'est grâce à l'équanimité que l'amour ne tombe pas dans le piège de l'attachement
Il empêche aussi, l'éconimité empêche que la compassion se dévie dans ce qui est le plus proche ennemi, c'est-à-dire la tristesse.
L'éconimité empêche aussi la joie de dévier, mal tourner vers l'excitation.
Si vous prenez une vertu, elle a toujours...
Si vous prenez n'importe quelle vertu, elles ont toutes bien sûr un contraire, mais elles ont toutes aussi ce qu'on appelle un ennemi proche, dans lequel on peut dévier sans s'en rendre compte.
Pour exemple, la courage.
par exemple le courage par exemple si on prend le courage qui est une vertu et l'âme contraire qui est la peur on la cowardise
Mais l'ennemi proche du courage, c'est se jeter bêtement dans le danger.
Et de ce point de vue, l'équanimité est vraiment la plus importante de toutes les vertus.
Elle permet à tous les autres d'être équilibrés.
Mais l'économie aussi a un ennemi proche.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on pratique toujours Metta quand on finit Vipassana.
Parce que l'économie peut dévier dans l'indifférence.
C'est pour ça qu'après Vipassana, on doit toujours réengager, vous savez.
Et c'est pourquoi, après Vipassana, on s'engage à nouveau dans l'amour pour tous les êtres.
Ce réengagement commence avec l'attitude juste.
Par exemple, c'est mon attitude principale, c'est la bonne volonté ou la bienveillance.
À ce moment-là, avec quelque chose de la personne avec laquelle je vais parler, les rencontres que je vais faire, c'est quelque chose qui va se transmettre dans ma vie, dans mon quotidien, dans mes relations.
Ok.
Ça va.
So now the next revelation.
Deuxième révélation.
Is answering the question that came up in one or two interviews.
concerne le progrès dans notre méditation, dans notre vie spirituelle.
Je pense que souvent, quand les gens viennent à la méditation, c'est un œil ouvert, ça apporte souvent un changement dans leur vie.
souvent quand les gens arrivent vers la méditation c'est quelque chose qui leur ouvre les yeux et qui apporte beaucoup de changement dans leur vie et même si ce n'est pas allé si loin ça a certainement apporté une nouvelle façon de regarder la vie et une certaine vivacité dans ce nouveau regard et parce que nous entrons dans la pratique avec ce que Zen appelle la tête des débutants
on a tendance à avoir un sens de progrès plutôt bon.
Et puis, après un temps, un an, deux ans, trois ans, quatre ans, tout semble s'éloigner,
Et après quelques temps, au bout de 2, 3, 4, 5 ans, on a le sentiment que ça traîne, que ça résiste, que ça n'avance pas.
Et on a ce sentiment de « Ah, il va falloir encore aller méditer ».
Et vous devez vous obliger à méditer parce que vous vous dites « Si je ne médite pas, ça risque d'être encore pire ».
Maintenant, c'est possible que nous devenions lazis, que notre pratique soit très chaude, et donc qu'il n'y ait pas de progrès.
Donc, c'est pourquoi nous faisons cette réflexion.
Si je vois que je suis en train de devenir lazis, alors je dois mettre un peu d'effort dedans.
C'est pour ça qu'il est bon de faire cette réflexion à la fin de la pratique de méditation.
Si on prend conscience à chaque fois que c'est toujours un problème de paresse, on pense, on se dit, bon, il va falloir que je fasse un petit effort.
Mais au bout d'un certain temps quand même, si on regarde en arrière, on s'aperçoit qu'il y a eu du progrès.
Donc j'ai juste écrit une ou deux choses ici.
La première chose, c'est juste notre compréhension de la vie.
Venir à travers les enseignements sur l'impermanence, sur comment nous créons notre propre souffrance, sur cette notion de non-Self, ça peut être assez révolutionnaire.
Déjà le fait d'avoir une bonne compréhension de l'impermanence, du fait que nous prenons conscience que c'est nous qui créons notre propre malheur, et du fait que nous prenons conscience que nous ne sommes pas ceux-là, ça peut être une véritable révolution dans notre façon de voir les choses.
Just the idea that nobody makes me angry, nobody makes me sad, etc. can have a revolutionary effect on a relationship.
La simple prise de conscience que ce n'est pas quelqu'un là-bas à l'extérieur qui me met en colère ou qui m'attriste, que ça vient de moi, ça c'est déjà une révolution dans notre relation aux autres.
On ne peut plus dire des choses à son, par exemple, son compagnon de vie, son époux, son mari, on ne peut plus lui dire, j'en ai marre, tu m'agaces, etc., ras le bol de toi, ça vient de toi.
Ce qui est un peu décevant.
Avant, c'était beaucoup mieux de les blâmer.
Donc, juste comprendre où notre personnalité, ce que nous créons nous permet, nous donne la liberté de l'enlever.
Et le fait de comprendre qu'en fait c'est nous qui créons tous nos états mentaux négatifs, ça nous donne aussi la liberté de les défaire.
Si nous les avons créés, nous pouvons les défaire.
S'il était possible que quelque chose ou quelqu'un dans ce monde puisse créer de la colère en moi, il serait impossible pour moi d'être libérée, de trouver les mêmes, si ça venait de l'extérieur.
Ou alors il faudrait que je m'en débarrasse, que je me tue.
C'est la très bonne compréhension que moi-même, je crée mon propre souffrance, qui est le premier pas sur la route à la libération.
Le premier pas vers la libération, c'est de prendre conscience que nous créons nous-mêmes notre souffrance.
Cette compréhension ne rend pas la vie plus facile.
On peut se dire, bon, j'ai bien compris ça, mais ma vie est toujours aussi misérable qu'avant.
Mais on va réaliser qu'effectivement on en est au début du chemin, que c'est une ouverture et que c'est vraiment la voie de la libération.
Et avec cette compréhension, on va rentrer dans le domaine de nos émotions, de nos états d'âme.
et nous commençons à devenir, vous savez, émotionnellement intelligents.
Donc maintenant, quand une émotion arrive, nous savons que nous devons être prudents de ne pas la permettre à hijacker notre esprit, à hijacker notre vie.
Donc au moins, les choses ne s'éloignent pas.
et au moins les choses ne deviennent pas pires c'est sûr que si on est dans la déprime c'est pas une situation agréable mais au moins on sait que ça ne vient pas d'ailleurs et le problème peut-être dans notre attitude c'est d'attendre trop dans les scriptures vous entendrez
souvent dans les enseignements dans les sutras du Bouddha on entend tel et tel moine et tel et tel moine après avoir entendu les enseignements du Bouddha sont partis dans la forêt et en très peu de temps ils ont obtenu l'éveil complet et les commentaires glissent cela avec 25 ans
Mais les commentaires, ils ajoutent que ce très peu de temps, en fait, c'était 25 ans quand même.
Donc, quand on lit cette écriture, on peut se dire, oh là là, c'est trop facile, il a eu la chance d'entendre les paroles du Bouddha, et hop, ça y est, mais non, en fait, il a fallu quand même du travail.
Et ce que nous...
Et quand on commence à s'ouvrir à tout ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de nous, on réalise qu'effectivement il y a beaucoup de travail à faire.
Mais il ne faut pas oublier que le travail n'est pas si dur que ça dans la mesure qu'il faut simplement être capable d'être avec, de supporter et de laisser les choses se développer, sortir et s'épuiser par elles-mêmes.
En général, ce n'est pas facile.
à cause des gens autour de nous, à cause de notre situation, nous tombons dans les mêmes vieux habitudes.
Donc notre pratique augmente et descend.
Et augmente et descend.
Mais au cours d'une période de temps, nous devrions voir un éclat lent.
Donc notre pratique, elle monte, puis elle redescend, elle monte, elle redescend, mais sur une certaine longueur, une certaine durée, on peut voir que quand même globalement, ça monte.
Une façon d'évaluer notre progrès, c'est de voir les changements dans nos attitudes.
Par exemple, avant, quelque chose qui nous mettait très en colère, aujourd'hui nous l'est peut-être moins en colère.
Ou bien nous sommes toujours très en colère, mais ça dure moins longtemps.
Nous devrions voir que nous sommes de plus en plus émotionnellement intelligents.
C'est important de prendre conscience qu'effectivement, sur le plan émotionnel, nous devenons plus intelligents.
Il y a un ami qui est venu me voir à Londres, il s'est perdu en arrivant dans la route, sur le chemin.
Et quand il est venu, il a pratiqué le Buddhism, et quand il est venu, il a dit, c'est drôle, il a dit, deux ou trois ans auparavant, j'aurais été en rage.
mais cette fois, je l'ai vu d'une manière différente pour venir le voir.
Vous voyez ?
Donc il y a des changements subtils dans la façon dont nous nous relions au monde.
Et nous nous relions à nous-mêmes, dans le monde.
La relation que nous avons par rapport à nous-mêmes, à l'intérieur de ce monde.
Donc, c'est un processus où notre conscience, notre compréhension des choses change très, très lentement, mais elle change.
Mais, chaque fois, au cours d'un temps, tu sais, 3, 5, 7 ans, tu peux regarder en arrière et dire, « Eh bien, il y a quelque chose de changé.
De temps en temps, il est bon, à peu près de 2, 3, 5, 7 ans, de se retourner un petit peu, de voir le chemin parcouru, de se dire, oui, quand même, il y a du changement.
On peut aussi regarder notre relation à notre travail.
Vous êtes une personne très fortunée.
vous avez par exemple beaucoup de chance de faire le travail que vous avez toujours voulu faire il y a beaucoup de gens qui finissent par faire un travail qu'ils n'ont jamais vraiment voulu faire soit parce qu'ils ne savaient pas trop ce qu'ils voulaient faire au départ
Ou parce qu'ils ont fait une erreur.
Mais plus souvent que pas, c'est juste la situation.
C'est le travail qui a été offert.
Et plus souvent, en général, c'est simplement parce que c'était le seul travail qu'on leur a proposé et qu'ils l'ont pris.
Souvent, les gens font des décisions sur la façon dont ils veulent aller quand ils sont 18, 19 ans.
Mais quand ils arrivent au milieu des 20 ans, ils se demandent, qu'est-ce que je fais pour ça ?
Par exemple, il y a des gens qui, à 18, 19 ans, se disent, je sais ce que je vais faire plus tard, etc.
Puis ils se retrouvent vers 25 ans et se disent, mais pourquoi je fais ce travail ?
Pourquoi je fais ça ?
Dans notre mentalité occidentale, on est très tourné vers le moi.
C'est à dire, je suis satisfait avec le travail.
C'est moi qui souhaite être satisfait de mon travail.
On estime que c'est mon droit, que la société devrait me donner le travail qui me convient.
C'est lié à cette idée que potentiellement nous sommes tous égaux.
Mais dans d'autres sociétés, comme les sociétés du Far East, les sociétés chinoises, l'accent n'est pas sur le fait d'être une partie d'un groupe.
Donc il y a beaucoup plus d'accent sur la responsabilité, la responsabilité.
Donc là on a plutôt des sentiments, on met l'accent sur la responsabilité, le devoir, le sentiment de devoir.
c'est vrai que ça existait probablement chez nous aussi peut-être jusqu'à la deuxième guerre mondiale nos parents, nos grands-parents avaient ce sentiment de devoir, de responsabilité beaucoup plus qu'aujourd'hui donc si je me retrouve avec un travail que je n'ai pas vraiment envie de faire mais que de toute évidence je suis capable de faire je pourrais avoir
peut-être que je ne le vois pas comme quelque chose qui va me permettre de m'épanouir dans certaines voies que j'aurais aimé développer.
Par exemple, je connais quelqu'un qui aurait aimé avoir sa propre ferme, son petit terrain sur lequel il aurait cultivé ses propres légumes.
Mais il n'a pas réussi à avoir assez d'argent pour acheter le terrain qu'il voulait.
Donc il a dû continuer son travail en travaillant pour d'autres personnes.
Donc il a dû continuer son travail à travailler pour d'autres En fait il faisait un travail très similaire mais il n'était pas en train de s'épanouir dans son but personnel
si quelqu'un passe trop de temps à ressasser ce genre de pensée du style je ne m'épanouis pas dans ce que je fais etc la vie va finir par devenir une déception pour lui mais si il tourne ça autour et plutôt que de faire lui-même ses propres désirs le focus de ses efforts
Mais s'il peut tourner la situation et au lieu de regarder les choses dans le sens d'un accomplissement personnel, il arrive à voir que ça peut être une action qui a une raison d'être au niveau d'un service, d'aider les autres, la société, à ce moment-là son travail peut prendre un sens à nouveau.
Un sentiment de service.
Maintenant, il y a souvent la question de l'ambition.
Donc, est-ce que l'ambition a à voir avec l'esprit, avec la pride, avec le pouvoir, et ainsi de suite ?
Est-ce que l'ambition, c'est lié à mettre son égo en valeur, le pouvoir, ce genre de choses ?
Bien sûr, ça peut être ça, mais si vous tournez la caméra, on peut dire, dans le sens du service, alors par contre, il peut y avoir la notion d'ambition juste.
Parce que vous dites à l'employé, qui que ce soit,
« Look, these are my talents, and you have a job going, and I think I can do it.
» Donc vous pouvez dire par exemple à votre employeur, « Écoutez, j'ai ce talent, vous avez un emploi qui est disponible dans ce domaine, moi j'ai ce talent-là et je peux le faire.
»
Dans ce sens-là, c'est ce que vous faites en offrant votre travail, vous offrez vos capacités, donc c'est un acte de générosité.
Ça ne veut pas dire que vous ne pouvez pas demander en échange un salaire équitable.
Mais ce n'est pas votre focus.
Le focus est ce don, ce service.
Mais il ne faut pas non plus que ce soit votre point principal.
Le point principal, c'est donner, offrir un service.
Quand j'étais encore étudiant, j'ai eu un travail dans une fabrique de gâteaux.
Et j'étais sur une ligne de production.
J'étais sur une ligne de production.
Il y avait toutes ces femmes qui travaillaient là, et moi.
Et les gâteaux, ils faisaient tout le tour d'une ceinture, d'une chaîne.
Et tout le monde devait ajouter quelque chose, faire quelque chose sur le gâteau.
Mon travail, c'était de mettre la cerise sur le gâteau.
Et ça allait très vite.
Je n'avais pas l'habitude de ce travail.
Et très souvent, je ratais le gâteau.
Alors, le responsable était en colère contre moi.
Mais les femmes étaient très gentilles.
Il y avait seulement un jeune garçon, un petit garçon, etc.
les pauvres, les jeunes, laisse le tranquille et c'était un tel contraste par rapport au reste de ma vie d'étudiant et tout ça que c'était en fait assez excitant, c'était intense et en plus à la fin j'avais de l'argent
et j'ai fait ça pendant 6 semaines l'été cette joie de travailler sur une ligne de production en faisant la même action a duré environ 4 jours puis ça a devenu vraiment barbare maintenant, parce que j'étais
je n'ai pas vu mon opportunité mais comme j'étais encore sur le plan spirituel pas encore éduqué je n'ai pas vu que j'avais une occasion, une bonne occasion ici j'espère que je pourrai trouver une opportunité pour grandir spirituellement
Et si aujourd'hui cette situation se présentait, j'espère que j'arriverais à en faire une occasion de grandir spirituellement.
Je mettrais tout mon cœur au service du gâteau.
Service du gâteau.
Pour le bénéfice de tous les autres.
Et dans cette concentration, je suis sûr que je grandirai dans cette vertu.
Par la mesure où j'ai été éduquée par les renseignements du Bouddha, je serais capable de voir que le cake, il apparaît, il disparaît.
Et je voyais que c'était une occasion de ne pas être moi-même, car je n'avais pas le contrôle.
Ça c'est une occasion aussi de voir le non-soi parce que j'ai aucun contrôle sur cette machine.
Et de cette manière-là, quand on regarde les choses comme ça, même le travail le plus simple peut être une occasion d'avancer dans la pratique spirituelle.
Quelqu'un a mentionné l'ennui comme un problème dans la méditation.
il ne faut pas oublier que quand on s'ennuie ça veut dire qu'on attend quelque chose d'autre que ce qui se présente c'est sûr que si on attend que notre méditation soit intéressante ou joyeuse et que rien ne se passe c'est sûr qu'on va s'ennuyer un sentiment d'ennui et rappelez-vous que quand l'ennui arrive l'ennui est l'objet de l'investigation
mais il ne faut pas oublier que si c'est l'ennui qui apparaît dans notre méditation l'ennui devient l'objet de notre méditation le méditant qui est là assis et qui voit que l'ennui apparaît il se dit ah tiens l'ennui voilà quelque chose d'intéressant à observer donc il ne faut pas s'éloigner de l'ennui il faut rester avec
Et n'oubliez pas que l'ennui peut être une attitude.
Et c'est une attitude qui va se déplacer partout où il y aura une attente ou une déception.
Donc, quand on apprend, quand on permet à l'ennui de...
s'exhaustent un peu, c'est le bouddhisme avec tout ce dont nous sommes bouddhistes.
Si nous laissons le bouddhisme s'exhauster un peu en méditation, ce n'est pas seulement le bouddhisme avec la respiration, c'est le bouddhisme avec tout.
C'est une attitude, c'est toute une attitude.
Oui.
Donc le Vénérable a retrouvé dans ses notes un discours que le Bouddha a prononcé sur le non-soi.
Après son éveil, le Bouddha a recherché les cinq ascètes avec lesquels il avait pratiqué.
Il a fait tout le chemin depuis Gaïa où il a eu son éveil jusqu'à Bénarès, le parc des nains, c'est-à-dire 300 kilomètres pour les retrouver.
Parce qu'il pensait que ses cinq amis qu'il avait eus étaient prêts à entendre son enseignement.
quand il s'est rapproché d'eux au départ ils avaient perdu tout respect pour lui parce qu'il les avait quittés mais quand il s'est rapproché ils se sont ouverts à lui à nouveau et il commence à leur parler et en leur parlant il leur demande constamment avez-vous jamais entendu parler comme ça ?
Et quand il leur parle, sans arrêt, il pose la question, vous m'avez déjà entendu parler comme ça avant ?
Et traditionnellement, on dit que le premier discours qu'il a prononcé, c'est celui où il a expliqué les quatre nobles vérités.
Donc c'est être noble vérité, il y a la souffrance, il y a une cause à la souffrance et c'est le désir.
On peut mettre fin à la souffrance en éradiquant le désir et voilà le chemin qui mène à la fin de la souffrance.
Et donc, selon l'histoire qu'on nous raconte, on dit qu'après cela, les ascètes et le Bouddha sont partis ensemble chercher de la nourriture au village.
Ils ont mangé leur nourriture, ils sont revenus, et ensuite le Bouddha a donné ce second discours sur le non-soi.
Et ce discours s'appelle le discours sur le non-soi.
Ainsi ai-je entendu
À cette époque-là, le Bouddha vivait à Benares, dans le parc des Dains, à Isipatana.
Et le Bouddha s'est adressé à ce groupe de cinq à sept, ses anciens compagnons.
Les monstres forment le corps
le corps lui-même est non-soi.
Cette traduction vient de Bhikkhu Bodhi.
Il a une bonne collection.
Normalement, c'est traduit comme non-soi.
Si le corps, la forme, était non-soi,
si ce corps était vraiment moi je n'aurais pas de souffrance je n'aurais pas de douleur à travers ce corps et on pourrait choisir comment on voudrait qu'il soit ce corps, cette forme on pourrait dire je veux que mon corps soit comme ceci que mon corps ne soit pas comme cela
mais dans la mesure où le corps cette forme n'est pas soi ce corps mène à la souffrance et il n'est pas possible de décider comment le corps doit être ou va être on ne peut pas décider que mon corps soit comme ceci que mon corps ne soit pas comme cela
donc il ne faut pas beaucoup de concentration pour se rendre compte que notre contrôle sur le corps est très superficiel est-ce que vous savez ce que votre foie est en train de faire en ce moment ?
Je ne sais pas.
Êtes-vous conscient que les cellules...
Les globules rouges venant de la moelle négative, la moelle des os.
Pensez non !
C'est le corpuscule que j'ai appelé.
Les corpuscules, les cellules rouges.
De toute façon...
est-ce que nous savons à chaque instant là maintenant que le dioxyde de carbone entre dans ce corps et que l'oxygène rentre et que le dioxyde de carbone ressort donc si vous regardez à chaque partie de la biologie du corps nous en savons très peu
Si on regarde n'importe quelle partie du corps sur le plan biologique, on en sait très très peu.
Il ne s'agit pas de le savoir dans sa tête, on peut connaître très bien la biologie, mais est-ce qu'on en fait l'expérience vraiment dans chaque instant ?
Est-ce que vous saviez que la pupille de votre œil change complètement chaque semaine ?
Quand vous vous coupez, qui la réhabilite ?
Et quand vous vous coupez, qui est-ce qui soigne ?
Quand on regarde vraiment le corps sous cet angle-là, on s'aperçoit qu'on est complètement étranger à notre propre corps.
C'est comme si on sortait d'un autre espace et tout d'un coup on se retrouve dans ce corps qu'on ne connaît pas du tout.
Mais parce que je peux tourner mon bras et parler, je suis en contrôle de ça.
Mais parce que je peux bouger mon bras quand je veux, que je peux parler quand je veux, j'ai l'impression que je contrôle mon corps.
N'oubliez pas que quand on définit le moi, le soi, l'entité, l'esprit, etc., c'est, il faut, la première chose qu'on pense, c'est qu'une personne comme ça, elle a un total contrôle sur la situation.
Si je ne peux pas contrôler quelque chose, ça ne peut pas être moi.
Non.
Donc, il dit la même chose sur le ressenti.
Et ensuite le Bouddha continue comme ça à dire la même chose pour d'autres éléments, notamment les sensations.
Il y a des sensations qui viennent du corps, ce sont des sensations.
Si vous mettez votre main dans de l'eau bouillante, vous ne pouvez pas l'empêcher de sentir que ça brûle.
C'est à l'extérieur de votre contrôle.
C'est en dehors de votre contrôle.
Et puis il y a tous les sentiments qu'on a dans le cœur, toutes ces émotions, ces chamboulements qui nous viennent par exemple quand on médite, ce sont des choses qui montent, sur lesquelles on n'a aucun contrôle.
Pareil avec les pensées, l'imagination, ça vient comme ça veut.
Et même la conscience dépend d'autre chose, on est conscient de quelque chose.
Regardez la vue, par exemple, la vision.
Il y a des photons qui font qu'on voit.
Si je suis dans une pièce sombre, je ne peux pas voir.
Si j'ai perdu mon eyesight, je ne peux pas voir.
Et si j'ai perdu la vue, je ne peux pas voir.
Et donc, je n'ai pas le contrôle de ma vision.
Ou plutôt, je n'ai pas le contrôle de ma conscience sensorielle qui concerne la vue.
Tout est conscient sensoriel.
Par exemple, si je regarde cette lampe, je ne peux pas voir autre chose.
Si je voyais autre chose, on m'emmènerait chez les fous.
Donc c'est la première chose, le contrôle.
La prochaine chose qu'il dit, c'est Qu'est-ce que vous pensez, les monstres ?
Est-ce que la forme, le corps, est permanente ou impermanente ?
Donc la deuxième chose qu'il dit, c'est qu'est-ce que vous en pensez, vous, moine ?
Est-ce que le corps, cette forme, est permanente ou impermanente ?
Et tout le monde répond, c'est impermanent, bien sûr.
Ensuite le Bouddha dit, alors ce qui est impermanent, est-ce que c'est souffrance ou est-ce que c'est bonheur ?
le mot souffrance c'est pour la traduction du mot duka en palais duka in its meaning just means hard to bear en fait la traduction littérale de duka c'est difficile à supporter so it's sometimes it's better to translate it as unsatisfactory souvent on traduit par souffrance mais on pourrait dire aussi ce qui est insatisfaisant it doesn't bring everlasting satisfaction
quelque chose qui n'apporte pas une satisfaction permanente, durable et donc les moines répondent c'est insatisfaisant effectivement quand c'est impermanent ça ne peut pas être satisfaisant
il n'y a pas de substrat qui est permanent mais qui change simplement de forme c'est en fait un disparaissance et un passé
en réalité ce qu'il y a c'est une apparition et une disparition à chaque instant de toute chose de tout ce qui apparaît c'est une impermanence radicale je sais, juste un moment donc il dit est-ce ce qui est impermanent non satisfaisant et subject to change fit to be called
« This is mine, this I am, this is myself.
» Si les choses sont impermanentes, si elles ne sont pas satisfaisantes, si elles sont sujettes au changement, pouvons-nous dire qu'elles nous appartiennent ?
C'est à moi, cette chose-là ?
« This I am, this is myself.
»
si par exemple vous avez un objet dans la main et vous dites c'est à moi c'est comme si vous suggériez que cet objet va rester le même d'instant en instant il ne va pas changer en apparence ce bol lui va rester pareil
et ça c'est l'illusion de notre existence parce qu'en réalité ce bol qui est là maintenant c'est pas le même que celui qui était il y a une seconde parce que le passé n'existe pas et le futur n'existe pas davantage quand on dit le futur on veut dire le prochain moment
Quand nous parlons de futur, en fait, nous parlons du moment qui va suivre.
En fait, notre existence, elle est sur le fil du rasoir.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on peut mourir d'une seconde à l'autre.
Alors, il dit...
il dit la même chose pour tout ce qui concerne les sentiments, les sensations, la conscience sensorielle donc il fait maintenant une statement très étroite donc, n'importe quelle forme
Et il conclut maintenant, en conséquence, toutes les formes, toutes sortes de formes, que ce soit des formes qui ont existé, qui vont exister ou qui existent maintenant, internes ou externes par rapport à nous, grosses ou subtiles, inférieures ou supérieures, lointaines ou proches,
toutes les formes doivent être considérées telles qu'elles sont réellement avec sagesse ce n'est pas moi ce n'est pas moi et puis il le fait avec toutes les autres catégories
Donc il dit ça au départ par rapport au corps et ensuite il le dit aussi pour les sentiments, les sensations, la conscience sensorielle.
Et ce passage en fait il le reprend souvent dans d'autres discours le Bouddha.
Et cela en fait ça vous donne le cheminement vers l'éveil.
Quand
en voyant cela ou en comprenant cela le disciple noble instructé devient désenchanté
quand le disciple le comprend et l'entend, il devient détaché, il perd toute... Non, désenchanté, comme un réveil.
Désenchanté.
Il quitte l'illusion, il perd ses illusions.
Il perd son illusion que le monde est comme ceci ou comme cela.
L'illusion tombe.
Et il devient désenchanté,
il perd toute illusion par rapport au corps, au sentiment, aux sensations, etc. et du fait qu'il a perdu ses illusions il perd tout attachement, tout intérêt pour ces choses et c'est grâce à ce détachement des choses qu'il arrive à se libérer et puis la personne sait
Et à ce moment-là, la personne sait, elle se dit clairement, cette naissance est détruite.
La vie spirituelle a été vécue jusqu'au bout.
Ce qui devait être fait a été fait.
Et donc, je ne reviendrai plus à la moindre forme de vie.
Fini les renaissances.
Maintenant, le Bouddha a été complètement libéré.
Le Bouddha, lui, était pleinement éveillé.
Il a continué à revenir.
Quand il a été complètement éveillé, il n'a pas disparu aussitôt pour autant, il a vécu encore 45 ans.
Donc quand vous lisez ça dans les Écritures, n'oubliez pas qu'il s'agit toujours de redevenir une personne, un soi.
Alors, si nous ne sommes pas une personne ou un soi, qu'est-ce que nous sommes ?
Donc je vais finir cette soirée en faisant quelques citations du Bouddha.
La première est
Déjà le Bouddha il préfère de parler de l'absolu de manière plutôt négative, dire ce que ce n'est pas Déjà on dit, il ne naît pas, il ne meurt pas Ce n'est pas conditionné Ce n'est pas créé
Donc vous obtenez ce genre d'explications de nirvana.
Ensuite il dit qu'il y a une sphère d'expérience.
La parole qu'il utilise est ayatana.
Et une façon dont il décrive un être humain c'est qu'on a six ayatanas.
Et il décrit un être humain en disant qu'ils ont, que nous avons tous six ayatamas.
Donc ce qu'il veut dire par là, c'est qu'il y a des expériences qui n'existent que dans leur propre sphère.
par exemple avec les yeux on peut simplement voir, on ne peut pas entendre donc il parle de nos six sens, le sixième étant l'esprit ce sont toutes des sphères d'expériences différentes il dit qu'il y a une sphère où il n'y a aucune de ces espèces de sens
Mais lui, le Bouddha, il dit qu'il y a une autre sphère par laquelle il n'y a aucune de ces bases sensorielles.
Dans cette sphère-là, il n'y a pas de venir, de partir ou de rester mobile.
Il n'y a aucun mouvement, ça ne change pas.
Il continue en disant qu'il n'y a pas de lune, il n'y a pas de soleil, etc. Donc tout ce qu'il n'y a, il n'y a pas.
Donc le Nibbana est une expérience.
Le Nibbana, c'est une expérience.
Et la personne qui fait cette expérience le sait, alors on est conscient.
Et la troisième quote vient d'un discours où quelqu'un demande au Bouddha, où sont les quatre grands éléments annihilés ?
Donc la troisième citation, c'est une personne qui a posé la question au Bouddha, à quel endroit est-ce que les quatre grands éléments sont annulés, disparaissent ?
Donc les quatre grands éléments sont le feu, la terre, l'eau et l'air.
cohésion et mouvement donc la terre c'est la gravité le feu c'est la température l'eau c'est la cohésion ce qui regroupe les choses et l'air c'est le mouvement et ça on le retrouve dans tous les anciens écrits chez les grecs donc ce que la personne demande c'est où vient le monde ?
En fait, ce que la personne posait comme question au Bouddha, c'est finalement, à quel moment, comment le monde arrive à disparaître, à se terminer ?
Et le Bouddha dit, c'est la mauvaise question, tu ne poses pas la bonne question.
La vraie question serait,
ou est-ce que les quatre éléments ne peuvent pas exister n'ont pas prise n'existent pas il dit il y a une conscience qui n'est pas colorée par aucun des sens y compris le mental l'esprit sans limites
Et cette conscience, elle n'a aucune limite.
Ce sont les phénomènes qui créent les limites, les choses tangibles.
Et elle est pleine de lumière dans toutes les directions.
Complètement éveillée.
Et c'est ça, la fin de la souffrance.
Maintenant, dans la tradition Theravada, vous pouvez dire que dans la...
Dans le Theravada, on constate que la façon dont le Bouddha s'exprimait, c'était toujours en termes d'expérience.
Dans toutes les Écritures, qui correspondent à 20 volumes énormes, cette phrase,
Cette phrase n'apparaît que deux fois, cette description de nirvana.
Deux fois seulement.
Tout de suite après la mort du Bouddha, il y a de nombreuses écoles de bouddhisme qui se sont créées.
Il y en avait déjà une centaine et il y en avait déjà 18, 100 ans après sa mort.
Et maintenant, il y a même toute une autre série d'écritures bouddhistes qui n'existent qu'en Chine, chez les Chinois.
Donc, on pense qu'il y a eu des coupures.
Donc, au fur et à mesure que les temps ont passé, la question d'origine a changé.
Au lieu de dire « quelle est l'expérience ?
», comme on pense qu'au départ le Bouddha l'a dit, c'est plutôt « quelle est la chose qui fait cette expérience ?
»
Et c'est là qu'apparaissent tous les enseignements qu'on connaît dans le Marayana, sur la nature du Bouddha, le grand soi.
Et a priori, on a l'impression que ces façons de voir les choses se contredisent.
Mais en fait, c'est juste un point de vue différent.
Maintenant, le Bouddha dit, quand nous sommes dans un état de compréhension, nous sommes dans la présence de Nibbana.
Donc, rappelez-vous, quand vous vous trouvez en méditation, en particulier, en tant qu'observateur, en tant que ressenti, en tant qu'expérienceur,
Donc rappelez-vous, quand vous êtes en méditation et que vous êtes en train d'observer, vous êtes vraiment dans la position de celui qui est en train de voir, d'expérimenter.
Vous êtes en train de faire l'expérience des sensations du corps.
Vous êtes en train de faire l'expérience de votre vie émotionnelle.
Vous faites l'expérience de vos pensées, en particulier des images qui peuvent venir.
Et vous en faites l'expérience de manière très claire, que ce sont comme des objets.
Oui.
Donc, c'est comme si nous nous sommes enlevé du corps, du cœur et du esprit et nous avons trouvé cette poste d'observation où nous pouvons observer
corps, cœur et esprit en processus quand cette position devient très claire pour vous vous pouvez réfléchir quelles sont les qualités de cet observer
Etant cette position d'observateur devient très claire pour vous, vous pouvez vous poser la question, quelles sont les qualités de cet observateur, cette chose qui observe ?
Parce que le Bouddha a dit que c'est là, quand on est dans cette position-là, qu'on est tout proche du Nirvana.
Je peux seulement espérer que mes paroles n'ont pas ajouté de la confusion.
Que vos pensées ont été clarifiées.
Et que vous avez grandi d'un enthousiasme profond.
Et que vous pouvez voir face à vous le moment final de la libération.
Laissez-vous l'atteindre plutôt tôt que tard.